the griffon a legendary creature known
for its recent depictions in medieval
folklore however its origins stretch as
far back as ancient Greece Persia and
Egypt the Griffin has the head and wings
of an eagle with the body tail and hind
legs of a lion the Eagle considered the
king of the birds and the lion the king
of the beasts combining the most
powerful elements of land and sky the
Griffin was considered an extremely
powerful and majestic creature Griffin's
were thought to be very wise and were
often shown God in the gold and treasure
of Kings some legends believe that
Griffin was more of a trickster much
like the sphinx who would challenge
people to solve its riddles the winners
would be allowed to keep the treasure
and their lives the losers would not
this Fink's is similar to the Griffin in
appearance with the body of a lion but
the head of a human there are several
different ways to spell the word Griffin
all of them indeed refer back to the
mythical creature
this variation was used in medieval
heraldry and is a term used to identify
a Griffin that was painted on a shield a
crest or a piece of armor the other
variations identify the creature
directly there are historians who
believe that the idea of the Griffin
came from dinosaur remains found from
the Cretaceous period the pentaceratops
was a four-legged Beast with a beaked
face whose remains were found near gold
veins anyone digging for gold in those
areas could have found the bones of the
pentaceratops and imagine a creature
very much like the Griffin digging and
holding gold the Griffin was commonly
shown to represent wisdom and power the
creature was often painted on the armor
and shields of knights throughout the
ages to embolden them and strike fear in
their enemies even the Gryffindor House
in Harry Potter was named after a
Gryphon with a lion on its crest in
Greek mythology the Gryphon was said to
have pulled the chariot of Apollo the
god of the Sun
Apolo would have to travel from the Sun
to the earth meaning he needed a
creature that could fly making the
Griffon the perfect choice he was also
considered a very wise god an attribute
shared by the Griffon during the Persian
Empire the Griffon was thought to be a
protector of evil and witchcraft what I
find most intriguing is the fact that
Griffon appears to be used more now than
ever the Griffon has become an iconic
character in the fantasy genre we often
see Griffin's and writings of fiction
and movies it's almost impossible to
play a fantasy based game without
finding a Griffon in there somewhere
despite the Griffins popularity they are
rarely mentioned by name
the Griffins lack of mention in
traditional literature means we don't
know much about them they have become
more of a symbolic creature commonly
used in legends and folklore this allows
the Griffon to be very easily identified
but also retains a level of respect and
mystery if you've enjoyed this video
then please go ahead and leave it a like
consider subscribing if folklore
mythology is something that interests
you if you have anything you'd like to
discuss or have any ideas for future
videos
then please go ahead and let me know in
the comments below as always I've been
your host mythology and folklore
explained